[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous video we have
considered the
this problem of the bending of beam
under lateral loading only
using the principle of stationary
potential energy
in this video we are going to address
the exact same problem but this time
using the principle
of virtual work so referring back to our
energy methods chapter we have already
seen
that for deformable bodies we proceeded
like this fashion
that we considered the the
expression of the principle of virtual
work which is delta w
equal to 0 are to be subdivided or
decomposed in this fashion and this
external work
we we saw that it could be written in
terms of this volume integral involving
the
body force in this fashion where of
course you note that these
eyes are the index notation i's indices
and this surface integration term
involving the traction
vectors t i multiplied by this first
variation of this
displacement vector okay
and we also noted that back in our
energy methods chapter applied to
deformable bodies
that this thing uh it it ultimately
became
equal to the volume integral of sigma i
j
delta epsilon i j okay so you please
refer back to the energy methods chapter
uh for this derivation now
what we are going to do is we are going
to neglect this body forces
okay we neglect this body forces
uh so that effectively we are just
dealing with this equation
ti delta uids
surface integration that is equal to the
volume integral
of sigma i j i j delta epsilon i j
d v so we want to apply this uh this
equation to our problem of this bending
of beam under lateral loading only
now if we want to proceed any further we
have to make some uh
some simplifying assumptions and those
will be
first of all associated with how the
geometry
is shaping up so let me go to the next
slide and discuss
that geometry so first of all we have
this beam uh so let me just draw it in a
slightly different
orientation like this
and note that
[Music]
our x axis is in this fashion
our y axis
will be in this fashion uh and the
z-axis
is pointed downward okay so unlike what
we
have discussed especially in connection
with our problems uh while dealing with
the caustic illness theorem on
deflections in the previous chapter
where we said that the y direction was
pointed downward for these beam problems
here the z z direction instead will be
pointed downward
for these beam problems and this y
direction uh will be
will be in this direction all right now
uh the the kind of simplifying
assumptions that we'll be dealing with
here
they fall under the uh under this
statement or under this
name of kinematical hypothesis
okay kinematical hypothesis
uh these are extremely extremely
important so these are the kind of
of pre-statements that we make about
the geometry or the deformation of the
body even before solving anything
so this is why they are referred to as
hypothesis we do not solve for them
rather we we assume them okay we hold
them to be true
and then based on that we proceed okay
all right so uh what we say
uh is that so let me let me draw this
diagram in a slightly
different orientation or more familiar
orientation
and see if it makes some sense so what
i'll do is i just
draw the center line of this beam that
is
that is aligned along this x direction
okay
so i'm just drawing the center line of
this
beam okay so you understand that this
is aligned along the x-direction
all right here of course the z direction
is pointed downward and
coming out of this out of the plane of
the screen
towards us is this y direction okay so
just a different way of looking at this
uh this thing of the same diagram here
now uh what we're going to discuss next
is of
very very great importance what we say
is that
as a result of the lateral loading that
is taking place on the top surface which
you can of course understand
with these kinds of this arrows like
this
okay
as a result of these loadings uh the
beam is going to deflect
up like that so here in this diagram in
a very explicit fashion
the center line of this beam which is
aligned along the x-axis
that is going to get deformed in this
fashion okay so this is a highly
exaggerated diagram
but we need to do this uh to to have
some clear understanding about
about the geometry of the deformation
okay so
one thing is very important to note here
is that a material point which may be
sitting here on the center line of the
beam
in this undeformed configuration in the
deformed configuration
after the deformation has taken place uh
this material point it just moves
here okay so what we mean to say is that
or rather uh it moves
exactly vertically downward so parallel
to this
to the z direction and it comes here
okay
so a point a material point which in the
undeformed configuration
on the center line of this beam uh it
moves
vertically downward to to come here okay
so which is to say that the material
points and because this is a generic
material point
uh no matter which material point you
take it is the same kind of situation
here they all come downward
like that which is to say that the
center line of the beam
does not move in along the x direction
either this way
or this way okay so that is a very
important
uh simplifying assumption all right
now uh what about the material points
which are not lying
on the center line of the beam so you
understand that the beam
is actually uh it's actually something
like this
okay so when when this thing deforms
uh you have the beam like that
okay so what i'm saying is that what
about points which are not lying
on the center line of the beam okay what
about those points
how do they deform and how do we
characterize their displacement
so in order to understand that uh what
we'll have to do
is to again appeal to the euler
bernoulli beam hypothesis
and uh through this statement uh it
should be very much
clear that when we are dealing with the
classical beam theory and we are going
to develop these things
up it is very much again contingent on
the euler bernoulli beam hypothesis
which we have already used while
while taking up our principle of
stationary potential energy
and which of course we have discussed so
many times in our undergraduate days
all right so the so whatever we are
doing within this
within the purview of this principle of
virtual work
is exactly the same or in parallel with
what we had done in the principle of
station potential energy
uh the root is different but it is it is
exactly
on the same kind of uh simplifying
assumptions
all right so so so getting back to the
to the
to the details of the euler bernoulli
beam hypothesis since
our plane sections remain plane plain
you have to understand that a if you
take a plane section here suppose
you take a plane section like that this
plane section is going to remain plane
okay so and it as part of the euler
bernoulli beam hypothesis
what we say is that uh this plane
section it remains
perpendicular to the uh
to the center line up so uh so in this
deformed configuration this thing is
going to be like this
if this is 90 degree here it also is 90
degree here
which means that a material point which
was here
located off center line it will be
located here
okay now how do we characterize the
deformation of this so if
we just zoom into this part a little bit
okay so suppose we zoom into this part
let me make that really large uh
okay so this is uh this is our off
center line material point
and we want to find out the deformation
or the displacement
associated with this okay what is the
displacement
uh along the x direction along the v
direct or the along the x direction on
the y direction
and the z direction okay so
uh we write that one by one so
u d w
okay so uh first of all let us take the
most challenging one the u uh you want
uh
so what we'll do is we'll we'll deal
with the slope now to
to find out this uh this this
displacement
and you note uh why this should make
sense here is that
if you if you draw a tangent here
okay and you consider the slope
okay so this is our dw
dx okay and
if you draw the vertical here this thing
is this distance that represents
the u now uh this
u that can be given by this kind of a
theta okay and you note
that because this entire angle is 90
degrees
here okay so to understand that
this thing here is 90 degrees if this is
theta this is 90 degree minus theta and
again
this angle is also 90 degrees so
uh we can we can understand that there
is a connection between this thing
and this dw dx okay so
uh let me write this down
so because these angles are going to be
small so tan theta is
almost equal to theta
and this thing this theta is going to be
equal to
ewtx okay
or rather it should be the other way
around that make more sense
so theta is approximately equal to
theta is approximately equal to tan
theta
and tan theta is equal to d w dx this
should make more sense
now this uh this distance
u uh you see
this is along the negative x direction
okay this is along the negative x
direction and
uh this this uh this distance
you can understand that that is nothing
but the
z coordinate of the material point under
consideration
if this is z okay if this is z
can we not write the u the magnitude
u as z times theta
the only problem here is that this
displacement
because of the particular way that we
have oriented our
our geometry this is taking place this
displacement is taking place
in the negative x direction so we have
to put this minus sign here
and then we are all set
right so take a moment to realize what
has gone on here
so we have basically written this like
uh
they basically use the theta here to be
approximately equal to this
ewtx so and
this distance this distance here
that is said okay the z coordinate
of the material point the generic
material point
under consideration here okay so this is
the z
from the from the undeformed or the from
from the under form center line
okay or directly from the center line
okay now what about the v
so what we say as part of our
kinematical hypothesis
is that there is no displacement of the
material points
in the out of the plane direction or out
of out of the screen direction
okay so this is going to be equal to
zero so the material points do not move
out of the the plane of this string okay
or
rather we should say that they do not
move uh
in a direction which is perpendicular to
the
x-z plane okay
next what about w so what we say here
is that w is a pure function of
x that is our kinematical hypothesis
okay it is not a function of why it is
not a function
of said w is a pure function of
x okay so
so what we are saying here basically is
that if
our our center line has moved
a distance w okay
so also this material point has moved a
distance
r w in the z direction that's all there
is to it
okay so if what we are saying here is
that
uh
if
if this distance is w
okay so that is how the material point
sitting on the center line has displaced
if that is w then the material point
which is not on the center line
this material point that has also moved
w along the z direction
okay so uh it may not seem like much
but this actually sets up um that
support very beautifully
for all our subsequent derivations so
as a first step to all the to all those
subsequent derivations what we're going
to
do is use the strain displacement
relations which we're all very familiar
with
to obtain the various components of the
strain
epsilon x x is
del u del x and that is going to give us
minus z d square w
d x square
epsilon yy is equal to
del p del y that is zero
epsilon zz is del w del said and because
w is a pure function of
x this is going to be zero
next we write the epsilon x y
which is half del u del
y plus del p
del x and that you note is
zero because u here
this u is not a function of y because
the z certainly is independent of y
and w here you know it is a pure
function of x
okay so and v of course is 0. so overall
this is
zero next epsilon y z
is half del
t del z plus del w
del y the second term this w is a pure
function of x so del w del
y is 0 and del and this v is 0 so this
is
0 and finally epsilon z
x we have
for this del w del
x plus del
u del said
and uh del w del x is of course del
and the same thing because of w is a
pure function of
x so this is basically d w d x
and del w del z you note from here
that uh all that is that it's going to
give us
is this dw okay because
that gets differentiated out so this
also becomes
equal to zero okay so
the only non-zero component of the
strain that we end up with
is this epsilon xx okay now
at this point uh you may be tempted
to directly go on and apply
uh what we know uh from our from our
previous studies
of the the linear elastic material
behavior
uh the general relations involving the
lambda and the g
but i i want to point out here that
within the purview of the classical beam
theory
what we are instead going to use is how
we are going to use
within the scope
of the classical beam theory
we just use sigma x x is equal to
e epsilon x x okay instead of the more
general relation
we just use this simpler formula
okay now where does this leave us and
please note that whatever we are doing
here this is very much consistent with
what we did
in the background of our development of
the principle of stationary potential
energy or the background use of the
application of this
principle of stationary potential energy
so so back when we used uh things like
uh m square by e i uh
uh inherent within those formula is the
use of
these kinds of formulas sigma xx is
equal to e epsilon x x
instead of the more uh general up
thing okay now uh
what we are going to do is we are going
to make this and this substitution
back in what we have so so we substitute
this
in the statement that we had obtained
earlier
this one
and see what happens so for our problem
you note
that uh this ti times delta ui this is
basically
the uh the representation of the work
done
by the externally applied fraction and
the externally applied fraction
for our problem is uh through that
through that distributed load q
and the the the first variation of the
displacement vector
that only involves the delta w okay so
all that we have to do is write that
properly
so we have q delta w
for the left hand side and
we don't have to worry about the surface
integral here because
uh the way that this q is written that
already takes into account the the
contribution over the
entire top surface of the beam uh so
that is already
integrated out up and we are left with
just the integration
over the length of the beam so so uh you
understand that this surface surface
uh integration is actually like over the
over the length of the beam as well as
over the over the width of the beam but
this q is
written or given to us in such a fashion
that it
already takes into account uh within it
the
the contribution over the entire uh top
surface
width okay so we don't have to write
that explicitly
now this thing is going to be equal to
sigma
xx delta epsilon
x6 dv
and we are going to use e
times epsilon xx here
dv and in the next step we are going to
uh we are going to
write this as
0 to l that takes care of the
integration over the entire length
minus h by 2 to h by 2 this integration
it takes care
over the for the the height of the beam
so that is along the z direction
and this outside integration the 0 12
that is over the x direction
now if you please note that if we just
stop here then this is not quite right
because this is here this here is a
volume integral and here we have just
integrated over two coordinates so what
about the integration over the
y coordinate so that is basically
so then since there's not going to be
any variation along the y
direction so what basically happens is
that we just have to multiply
by this width of the beam which is b you
can
of course write this thing as uh 0 to b
integration over the whole thing as dy
but none of this is dependent along the
along the y direction so that that
integration will just give us
as a result this b okay so here b
is the width of the beam
so along the y direction
all right so all that you have to do now
is just replace this epsilon x6 but what
we have by what we had obtained
in the in the previous uh slide here
this epsilon x6 is equal to minus z
d square w d x square
minus said d squared w dx squared
and this delta epsilon x6 so for that
what we have is minus z e square
delta w dx square
okay so uh what we are doing as uh
simplification is that we are first
taking the delta of this
minus z d squared w d x squared and then
we are taking the delta within the
within the differentiation okay and of
course this delta z also does not
contribute that's zero
uh so we have this thing
all right so uh uh
if we go to the if we go to the next
page what we are going to do is
uh this minus z and this minus z that
becomes z squared
uh so let me let me just try to copy
this thing
go to the next page here
the left hand side remains as it is
the right hand side is this entire
term here i don't need that
equal to sign here
okay let me just align that properly
so proceeding with our steps
uh what we'll have is
b z squared e
is here
all right
now you see this
e is certainly independent of z the b is
independent of z
this w is certainly independent of z
because we
according to our kinematical hypothesis
this is
only a function of x similarly this is a
function of x
so what we can do is we can take this
term out of
so considering this integration over the
with respect to z
we can take the e out we can take the b
out we can take this one out and we can
take this one out
but we of course cannot take this out of
this uh integration with respect to x
we just keep it like this
you see there is a nice bit of
simplification and if you note carefully
what this is going to give me
effectively
so you consider this e times b
times this term that is just going to
give me
e i because this is
that cube by 3 and if you just carry out
the integration you will see that
b times this result is nothing but the
second moment of area
okay so i am using this thing that e is
equal to
b times
right
do you see what we have managed to
obtain
we have arrived at a step
where
we have this term
as an integration over the length of the
beam
and then if we take the left hand side
to the to this side
transpose it
we have this thing now you please
compare this
with what we had obtained in the
intermediate
step in one of the intermediate steps uh
while
carrying out our previous derivation you
know in the in the previous video
on the on the principle of stationary
potential
energy so compare this
in the in the application
of principle of
stationary
potential energy so previous video
so i'll just refer back to that slide
you note this one
okay you note this step is it not the
exact same thing
okay this particular equation that we
are obtaining here
is it not the exact same thing that we
had
an intermediate step so this
intermediate step here
is the star marked equation
so this equation is exactly the same as
before
so in terms of the subsequent
mathematical development it is
absolutely going to be no difference
between what we have here
what we what we wish to do here and what
we have already done
in that in that previous video so
instead of investing any more time uh
let me just refer you back
to that exact same derivation the
governing equation
that will arise as a result of that of
those steps
the boundary conditions that will arise
as a result of those steps
are going to be exactly the same so
i will not invest any more time on on
that derivation
and leave you with the thought that that
yes
because we are proceeding in exactly the
same parallel fashion
in the principle values while applying
the principle of stationary potential
energy
and the principle virtual work uh these
are equivalent
and parallel things we are going to end
up with
the same kind of governing equations and
boundary conditions of course it is
extremely important
that to note that the principle of
virtual work
is much more general than the principle
of the stationary potential energy
because when we are doing
when we're doing this the principle of
virtual work we started out with a very
very general thing without
specializing to any kind of material
behavior or geometrical simplifications
but once we do use once we invoke the
the dynamical hypothesis once we
uh so basically invoke or appeal to the
euler bernoulli beam hypothesis as well
as the linear elastic which will be here
it is then that we make the uh we
proceed
parallelly to the uh principle of
stationary potential energy
so there is a uh it is it is as a choice
of
making this kind of a of a parallel
progress along the line of the principle
of stationary potential energy that we
that we arrive at the same kind of
governing equations and boundary
conditions
which is to say that we could have
proceeded
in a different fashion so suppose we go
back here
we go back here we we do not use this
kinematical hypothesis
rather we use something else that does
not mean that we are not using the
principle of virtual work because if you
go back to the previous slide
okay up to this stage this is very
general okay
so um so once we once we come to the
point where we do have to use this
kinematical hypothesis and
we wish to use something more advanced
than this
suppose we wish to use something uh
which is usually referred to as the
demotion for beam theory then we have to
make modifications in this kinematical
hypothesis
but once we do that the the expressions
for the strains are going to be somewhat
different
and then we can substitute those
expressions in our in our
you know subsequent steps so when you
make the substitutions we can make
different sorts of substitutions and
proceed and will of course end up with
different sorts
on of course in that case we are not
going to end up with this
it's going to be somewhat different and
then finally as a result of all that
development
we are going to end up with different
sorts of boundary uh governing equations
and boundary conditions
compared to the principle of stationary
potential energy
okay so uh so usually
what the understanding is that uh
it is is much more general and more
fundamental to proceed
up from the principle of virtual work uh
but of course for these kinds of very
simple uh situations
and where we know that we do wish to use
the
the
the simplest of dynamical hypothesis and
the principle of
uh and the linear elastic material
behavior
then uh of course they are going to be
parallels okay
uh because the the principle of
stationary potential energy that itself
can be
uh generalized but uh we we are not
going to go into those sorts of
discussions
and i'll leave you uh with this thought
of
the nice parallelism between the
principle of virtual work
and the principle of stationary
potential energy all right
on that note i'll end this video thank
you very much